success to be able to operate in
relationships or be willing to submit to
whoever the man is because you've seen
it growing up or does it just doesn't
not have an effect I I think that's a
really great question I know a lot of
people who grew up in dual parent
households and they saw their mother
getting cheated on and staying and like
I know like someone recently they were
married for like 25 years or so or 23
years and she left basically when the
kids were old enough to just like none
of them were in high school anymore
um and I I remember when I was talking
to her she felt like she was setting her
kids up for Success because we're all
under the same roof
um they have a better chance of whatever
right and it still was damaging because
you are witnessing your mother tolerate
disrespect for uh security how did the
kids know
how the kid how the kids know what that
she was being cheated on
it was something that
this particular situation it was I know
one instance was like one of their
family friends oh [ __ ] yeah it was
really close to home stuff and there was
another another scenario where it was it
was one of the family friends they were
cheating on or is that told them
um no it was they were cheating with one
of their family friends so like someone
like let me go over to her house all the
time so my dad is sleeping with her oh
so he they would see the parent cheat it
I'm not exactly I don't I don't think it
was they physically saw it but it was
something that the mom would share
um that they would hear arguments too
like if they weren't even if they
weren't involved in the actual argument
they would overhear
um which obviously you know showing
exposing your kids to that stuff is one
thing but the other instance was
um the dad was going out to the club
with like the sun and he had a girl with
him so it's like that direct like I
don't respect your mom in this way I can
do what I want to do and your mom's
still going to stay so that's where I
feel like it really depends on what's
going on in that household because
seeing your mom be basically
disrespected for
comfort
it's like it sends the wrong message
about love I agree like blatant dislike
I can't believe he brought his son to a
club and [ __ ] like that that's crazy
yeah like the girl with him but I just
think sometimes you know we never talk
about like the women's part to play in
this and like one one in four marriages
are sexless
one is horror and so I just think if
you're gonna starve a man and he's
begging you to sleep with him and
someone comes on a platter like that's
why I say we never talk about why the
men cheat and a lot of people will take
this out of context like I believe in
cheating but like there are times where
the woman is not sleeping with the man
and then he cheats but he's not
naturally inclined to
and and that's a conversation we don't
really have I'm not saying it's okay but
it's almost like what did you what did
you expect but at the same time too like
again like let's just like I said make
it with me and you like if you're my
girlfriend and you don't want to sleep
with me the the my first go-to isn't to
go try to sleep with someone else I'm
not getting it from you I would want to
explore the emotional depths of whatever
you're feeling what am I not doing why
do you not want to be close to me I want
to be intimate with you but you're
thinking like a woman and that that's
how a woman right right but like like
men it's just come out you know how guys
are like I'm sure you you especially
like like being as beautiful as you are
like most guys if you put yourself on a
platter in front of them would be down
yeah I mean yeah yeah that's saying much
but yeah yeah I mean but that's that's
what I'm saying like men men have you're
given him sex he'll still cheat because
there's options I I would say most men
that have women on them on a silver them
on a silver platter will cheat yeah like
I would say but not all men most most
men work a normal nine to five they go
to work they come home there's maybe one
or couple girls in the office whatever
that he might cheat there but most men
girls aren't really checking for so if
you date an average guy unless you're
starving him of sex it's a lot of work
for men to go out and get sex that's why
I say what part did you have to play in
him cheating like okay if you you were
with a elite athlete right
they're just gonna cheat that's just I
see the normal I saw D3 basketball
players
[Laughter]
but okay but like your average nine to
five Joe it's a bunch of work for him to
go out and get a girl so it's like what
part did you have to play a lot of women
are always nagging on their husbands
they got they gained a bunch of weight
after they had a kid Brittany showing us
first hand you don't have to do that and
and it's like then they stop sleeping
with him and the men are like wait wait
wait wait I thought I got a 120 pound
wife that was good to sleep with me all
the time now she got the ring where I'm
locked into a contract for life and you
could take my kids with me and my money
and put me on child support all the
stuff and now you're gonna gain a bunch
of weight and not sleep with me wig what
did you expect to happen you're not
holding up your yeah and so men like
that's another reason men don't want to
get married because they're like oh I
had a guy tell me this he's like I don't
want to get married I don't want her to
get fat but you know why this is why a
lot of the time as well amazing just say
one thing
a lot of the time the reason why some
some men get a little bit messed up
comes down to
insecurities and let me land and I'll
explain to you why a lot of the time the
women that let themselves go in a
relationship or in a marriage is also
down to the fact that men now that they
own the woman they do not want the woman
to be approached they don't want the
woman to be desired by other men it
comes down to the whole territorial
thing which then means that you are now
going to punish or going to complain are
you going to put the woman in a position
where she feels like whatever she looks
like is a problem so she'll let go of it
and she won't even work for it that's
also another thing another side of
things women don't just let go of
themselves for no reason they start to
let go of themselves because there's no
desirability in general many to
understand as a woman for you to be
beautiful and to feel beautiful is not
just about you telling me that I'm the
most beautiful girl in the world you
know I just to me it was just nonsense
girls let themselves go because they eat
too much and they're lazy I know a
couple girls that got married and gained
like 50 pounds none of them are happy
they gain the weight they always they
were thinner but they're too lazy to fix
it
it's like I don't know and now they have
the ring it's like less incentive you
know when you get you guys know when you
get break up with someone you are in the
gym you're trying to look like you're
not me too me too I'm not saying I'm
special me too or in the gym we're
trying to like get our bodies right all
this stuff and then we get a man and we
don't we don't keep it I mean the way I
was raised you occased it to your man
say you've got this is your cake and I'm
not I'm not saying you you need to look
good friends so I don't know about
letting yourself go uh no I I've got him
now I need to keep him I I agree with
you but I'm not saying you in particular
I'm saying this is what the men are
saying this is these are the issues
they're saying yeah obviously I I think
it's wrong like when you get into a
relationship I don't think like letting
yourself go I think it's a problem as a
woman like why should you do that
because it's Gonna Leave You So I I do
agree do you think a man can leave a
woman if she lets herself go she's asked
her multiple times to lose the weight
and she won't do it
I wouldn't say assuming let's say
there's no kids involved because kids
kind of change things well let's say
there's no kids well to be honest yes
because no but it's not unfair you'll be
telling your guy how many times do you
say listen I told him a million times to
not this do not do this I told him a
million times to get up off his ass I
told him a million times to do this yeah
he didn't do it I left him if you as a
man you're speaking to you to your girl
and you're trying to make sure that she
improves and she is better and she's not
doing that the problem is not that she's
not losing the weight the problem is the
mentality which is the fact that you are
not willing to be better and get better
so that we can both be happy and have
the Sun for Life see this is what this
is this is what this is what I mean when
I say it's like there's little things
that are open missandry against men and
we don't always realize it so like in
this instant you kind of hesitated but
if I came forward and I'm not saying I
don't think it's intentional but if I
said yeah I left him because he wouldn't
work he wouldn't get a job you would be
like yes girl like and you know yeah you
and you know you would you shouldn't be
with a bum and it's like that's a female
bum a 300 pound whale I'll say it I'll
say it again be careful be careful the
reason I'm a bit more sensitive towards
women is because I obviously you guys
are saying your reality is different but
my reality it's always been you've got
to be better for your man so my world
has always been about the men and and
I'm like so what is it doing for me so
yeah I've got to learn to cook clean do
all this stuff take care of my man but
how is he helping me emotionally how is
he helping me feel good but man that's
not their job to help you emotionally
that's like where I think that's no okay
okay
yeah but like they don't want to they
don't they don't they don't want to hear
so this is this is doing all this for
what what am I like okay you can't I'm
not saying they should never like talk
to you or what like ignore you all the
time but I'm just saying like like
typically historically you wouldn't even
see your husband that much that's not
their job you vent to your friends like
your relationships with men and this is
something I learned like one time okay I
had an ex-boyfriend and I was talking I
was like this person and he's just like
I don't care
and at first I was like
what do you mean you don't care like I
was like that was so rude but I like sat
and lit thought about it and I'm like
you know I'm like dumping my problems
onto him and that's not his job he's not
my therapist like we don't want a guy
that's dumping all his problems on to us
we're being a companion
right but I'm saying I'm saying so again
again like they remember this is things
that we look for from men but men don't
look for from us and so and that's
that's what all this for you what are
you doing for me typically what I'm
saying I don't want I don't want to be
cooking for my man I'll tell you I'll
tell you that's what they look so but
I'm saying like that you're always gonna
get protection and that's the one thing
like so okay okay okay okay okay but if
the world but if the world
living living here living here I I wish
I had a boyfriend because it it scares
me a lot of times like living like just
you know like people know where the
studio is sometimes right and there are
crazy people and I'm like it would be so
nice if I had a guy here just like not
even just to like if he was staying here
and it would be like like if something
happened I know he would like there's
some level of comfort you have with just
having a man next to you and knowing
that if [ __ ] goes south you don't have
to call the police that he's going to
protect you like you know they say women
prefer fat guys with muscles over skinny
men yeah because because it's like Ellie
I ever was that I agree that's I would
take that too not sure and you know why
why for example for me I love to cook
for people and one of the things that I
love the most as well is to cook for my
man and I'll tell you why because at the
end of the day whether or not know I'm a
bad girl and I'm you know successful and
I can do my own [ __ ] and I don't need
the man it feels nice to me to show
somebody you know love through food love
through things that you are actually
much better at doing obviously I would
don't mind if a man can cook for me
great if you can cook for himself great
but I like to cook why because then when
I go out he'll pay for Me Maybe or he'll
fulfill a certain role of chivalry that
today in today's age is not needed but
because I fulfilled my role of chivalry
as a woman he'll give me that because we
can't say oh he needs to pay a guy that
don't pay on the first day a guy don't
don't do this all of these things okay
there's there's a transaction with that
which means you also cater to him if a
woman don't cook on the second date then
she then she ain't wifey we've never as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible